Ggplot allows us to easily create various summaries of
our data and plot them. This could be especially useful
for quick exploration and for combining plots of raw data,
like our original scatter plot with displaying summaries. This plot
is one of those displaying summaries and I want to
be able to display it over the original plot we
had for friend_count versus age. Let's see that first original
scatter plot again. Now since all these points are black,
I'm going to change the color of these. So that way when
I overlay the summary, it's easier to see. I'm going to make
the color here orange. So now, I've got my scatter plot
and I want to overlay the summary that we have from before.
I want to put this on top of this. I can add
a geom_line to our plot to do so. Here I'm going to
pass the parameter stat and set it equal to summary, and
I'm going to give it a function for y. The fun.y parameter takes
any type of function, so that way we can apply it
to the y values. In this case, I want to take
the mean. And there it is, this is my summary line
are the mean friend count by age, over my raw data
or my scatter plot. This plot immediately reveals the increase in
friend_count for very young users and the subsequent decrease right after
that. We can add even more detail to this plot by
displaying multiple summaries at the same time. Despite having this conditional
mean plotted, we can't immediately see how dispersed around
the mean. For example, are the median friend_counts for
age 30 in this region or did they span
all the way up to 2,000? Certainly we can see
that most users, even young ones, don't have more
than 2,000 friends. We can help ourselves understand this conditional
distribution of friend_counts by also plotting quantiles of the
data. So let's use the 10%, 50% or median and
90% quantiles. We'll start by adding our 10% quantile summary line
to this plot. So I'll add another geom_line, I'll pass it
a stat of summary and then for the function, I'm going to
pass it quantile instead of mean. I need to set the
probability equal to one tenth or 0.1. This code gives me
10% quantile on my plot. Now I want it to appear
different from the mean. So, I'm going to add some details to
color it and to make it dash. I'll set the line type
table to two to make it dash and I'll set the
color equal to blue. There that's much better. Now to add
the 90% quantile, I would just need to change the probability
here to 0.9 instead of 0.1. So I'm going to add another
line. I'll use the same parameters as before and then just
change the probability. So here we can see that 90% of
users have friend counts below this line. The last thing I'll
do is add in the 50% mark, which is the median. Now
I won't make this geom_line dash, but I will make the color blue.
Now this is quite a plot. I want you to try creating this
same plot in R and try adding a coord_cartesian layer to zoom in
on different parts of this graph.
Look at the documentation for coord_cartesian if
you need help. And definitely be sure that you understand all of this
code. I know that there is a lot going on here. Once you've
got a strong idea of this plot and you've explored it a bit,
I want you to make some observations about the plot. What do you notice?